it's really easy to see that that life
that you want will still be possible if
you start at 30. your 20s are about
being able to feel lost and be
comfortable with that feeling and try
out a couple of different things it's
all right to feel lost hello and welcome
back to Deep dive the weekly podcast
where every week it's my immense
privilege to sit down with authors
academics entrepreneurs and creators and
other inspiring people and we talk about
how they got to where they are and the
strategies and tools we can learn from
them to help build a life that we love
today I'm joined by Gemma spec Gemma is
the podcast host of the psychology of
your 20s the podcast that talks through
some of the big life challenges and
changes of your 20s and what they mean
for our psychology the thing that also
links to this quarter life crisis is
this idea that the decisions that we
make now are going to be the sole reason
for our happiness in the future and that
is not the case because your life is
going to go a million different
directions in a blink of an eye now when
another podcast Community know that
Gemma was coming on the Pod and asked
them to send in the challenges they're
facing during the 20s the thing that
really stood out is this feeling that as
we transition into adulthood it can feel
like you're on a bit of a hamster wheel
of trying to balance all these different
aspects of your life one of my good
friends said this to me the other day I
have no idea where I'm going to be in
like five years time or 10 years or when
I'm 50 and if I continue to work in my
nine to five I would know I would know
that you know you move up between you
move up the ranks you'll pay increases
you have a family all those things right
and what she said to me and it really
stuck with me was
Gemma welcome to the podcast how are you
doing I'm doing so well thank you so
much for having me on I'm very excited
to chat with you today okay so
you are the expert on the psychology of
your 20s um and one thing that often
comes up when people talk about that is
this idea of a quarter life crisis so
what is a quarter life crisis and yeah
how do we how do we think about that
term yeah so the term quarter life
crisis I think we need to think about it
in the context of a midlife crisis right
that was the first idea that kind of
came before the quarter life crisis and
we think about it a lot in terms of a
lot of men you know they they reach
middle age and they go and buy like a
red convertible they get like a younger
girlfriend that's a very outdated idea
we're seeing that earlier and earlier
people are having these kinds of
crises or Forks in the road where they
have to make these massive decisions or
they feel like they do and what that
creates is a sense of anxiety a sense of
dread a sense of stress and then
sometimes a sense of needing to be
spontaneous and to take a risk so
essentially the quarter life crisis
occurs between the ages of around 20 to
30 and it involves someone
experiencing this sense of what am I
doing with my life and where to next so
that's essentially the idea that we're
talking about today and this seems to be
a relatively modern phenomenon like what
do you think is is driving it so
prevalent like I get I guess in the last
sort of five to ten years I've been
hearing about this but I guess I feel
like in the early 2000s it probably
wasn't really a thing yeah that's
actually such an interesting question
because I've
this a lot as well and I think if we
take it back even further to like the
1950s the 1960s there was this very
almost narrow blueprint of what our
lives would look like we went to high
school we graduated went to University
picked up our life partner got a great
job nine to five bought a house had
children
retirement death and that's really
depressing right but it was very narrow
and I think as we entered into the early
2000s a few things happened and the
first was of course the accessibility of
the internet and social media and
suddenly not only did all these new
career Pathways become available a lot
more opportunities for entrepreneurship
but then we also have this element of
being able to look at what everyone else
was doing with their lives and compare
to that so we see people now who are
traveling the world people like you and
I who are doing this for a living it's
very unconventional I would say I always
see people who are working the the
traditional nine to fives we have this
very amazing spectrum of things that we
can compare ourselves to and I think
that kind of flips the switch where
we're like oh my goodness what am I
doing and then to further that we're
also seeing things like a lot of
environmental factors right like our
external factors like we have a
recession coming up we're not going to
deny that there's all this uncertainty
around the climate around our financial
situation around Financial Security and
what that creates is a lot of anxiety
around okay I need to be future prepared
but then I also want to have fun because
this is my 20s and everyone tells me
this Narrative of you should take risks
you should make mistakes so that's kind
of this friction point where it's I
almost imagine it kind of like a tree
and all throughout like our teens and
our young years it's going the same
direction and then suddenly we're like
oh there's actually I'm in charge now I
this I get to make these decisions there
are all these people that I can compare
myself to and there's all these new
careers and all these new options but
then also this these like these little
thoughts in my brain and these external
factors that are challenging that and
it's kind of like the tree just goes
like and we can't really see where
everything's going and where that will
take us sorry that was a bit of a ramble
but I hope that makes it clear
absolutely yeah so um one thing I've
heard from a lot of people is and I
think when we pulled our um podcast
Community about this one thing that
really came up was people feeling lost
yeah
yeah and maybe I should have said that
earlier but that's essentially I think
all those feelings wrapped up in one
title and one word would be the we're
being lost would be the feeling of being
lost right and I think that all comes
down to this expectation that you need
to be on the right path right now you
need to have everything figured out
right now and that is not the case and I
think in our 20s we are bombarded by all
of these Life Choices that we need to
make we were talking about some before
right
should I move to a new country should I
go and do my doctorate degree should I
just quit my job and go traveling and
all of those things paralyze us because
we're overcome by this thing called the
Paradox of choice and I also think this
is something that's come up a lot more
in in the last like 20 30 years
we're presented with so many options
which is a good thing that it paralyzes
us and we can't even make one and there
was this really interesting experiment
they did on this a little bit of a
tangent but
these psychologists from Stanford they
went to the farmer's market and they set
up a stall for jam and on day one they
had 27 jams for sale and on day two they
only had five and we think and they
wanted to see how many how many times
people purchased the jam and on the
second day when people only had five
options their sales were like up 300 and
it shows us that we actually don't want
as many choices as we think that we do
and when we do have more choices we're
less likely to act on those and we feel
lost because we're unsure of whether
we're going to make the right decision
so that's another kind of psychological
element behind this experience
I guess part of this this feeling of
feeling lost or directionless is this
idea of
needing to have sorted out
like your ideal life yeah like I've
heard a lot of people say that like oh I
don't know what to do with my life
and and the implication there is that
that is a really bad thing yeah um and
sometimes even like when I talk to my
mum she will say that she'll look at my
career and say that like I don't have
any direction in my career or something
like that that's so funny and I kind of
be like that is true but it's also not
necessarily a bad thing but at the same
time the phrase you have no direction in
your career is definitely a negative
rather than oh you don't have any
directing career well done you yeah yeah
how do you how yeah what's what do you
what are your thoughts on that I really
I really like this this train of thought
here because I think about this a lot I
think that a lack of direction is comes
off very negative but it also means an
abundance of opportunity and that's
something that we need to realize and
one of my good friends said this to me
the other day because I recently started
doing my own show full time it was a
massive risk for me I took a massive
like step away from the financial
security that my nine to five offered me
I did something a little bit against the
grain and the thing that really like
struck me was because this path is
unconventional I have no idea like
podcasting hasn't really existed for
that long right I have no idea where I'm
gonna be in like five years time or 10
years or when I'm 50. and if I continue
to work on my nine to five I would know
I would know that you know you move up
between you move up the ranks you'll pay
increases you have a family all those
things right and what she said to me and
it really stuck with me was stop trying
to imagine what your life looks like
down to the detail and just imagine how
you want your life to feel like on an
average Monday afternoon
and I was like wow that is so profound
she was like picture yourself at 50 and
what are you doing on a Monday night
and what does that entail because you're
not going to be thinking about all the
all the Milestones that you hit you're
successful things you've done you're not
going to be putting the pressure on
yourself to meet all these certain you
know goals instead when you think about
it that way you just think about what
kind of Life do I want to be living what
emotions do I want to be feeling and you
acknowledge that there will be multiple
paths to get there and I think that
that's very liberating right so I said
to her like I would want to be living in
a big city and I'd want to be having
people over for dinner that I'd met you
know in various places maybe I'd have a
few people living with me who had picked
up along the way friends family random
acquaintances and I want to be able to
come back and talk to my friends or talk
to my partner about an amazing day that
I had and I want to feel loved and I
want to feel happy and it doesn't matter
what happened before that as long as I'm
in that spot and I think that is a much
better frame of mind to be in rather
than to look at your life as a series of
Milestones that you need to hit or a
series of decisions that you need to
make and a correct way of going about
your 20s and then also your broader life
does that make sense oh my God that's
such a good way of thinking about it
like what's yours can you picture what
you want when you're 50 Monday night at
50. yeah I think mine is
broadly similar
um
in that the feelings that I would want
is a feeling that I've spent the day
you know still working uh because I
enjoyed I enjoy working but feeling like
the work was interesting I had autonomy
and Independence I could kind of do what
I wanted maybe I learned something
interesting yeah maybe I shared
something interesting because for me
teaching and sharing is like a big part
of what brings me fulfillment and then
yeah go home or stay home uh in the
evening have friends over for dinner
um living in a place where it's very
easy for friends to hang out and maybe
have a family and kids and all that kind
of stuff that's the sort of feeling that
I would want if I imagine people I know
at 50 who have who are like working in
medicine for example
and the feelings of that seems to invoke
in them around like the day job that
feels like the opposite to what I would
I would want exactly but if I imagine
people who are authors like I know a
couple of authors in their 50s who can
just sort of spend the day
going for a walk on the Yorkshire in the
Yorkshire Dales and then writing about
whatever takes their fancy because you
know they've got an advance on their
latest book deal or because they've made
enough money through royalties to fund
their life and that seems like a good
place to be I love that and I don't know
what the Yorkshire is but it sounds
lovely but the but you know what's
really interesting is when you picture
that could you tell me like how much
money you were making no one ever thinks
like
in that in that thought exercise we
never sit there and think oh and my
salary will be this
and I'll be driving this car and
um by the way like I'm gonna have all
this money and savings and this is the
kind of clothes I'm gonna wear and none
of us think back to when you ask
yourself that question
it's you don't think like okay well what
were the things that that got me there
or what were the mistakes that I needed
to make or and it's it's really easy to
see that that life that you want
will still be possible if you start at
30 so your 20s are about being able to
feel lost and be comfortable with that
feeling and try out a couple of
different things you're it's all right
to feel lost feeling lost also means
having a lot of open doors
um linking back to that Paradox of
choice that we were talking about right
yeah this reminds me um have you come
across Tim Urban's blog post
he's got an amazing blog uh wait but why
uh and there's a blog post in that it's
titled something like life is a picture
but you live in a pixel
whoa and the way he describes it is like
you know you imagine like Mark
Zuckerberg and you think about the
picture of his life like oh he must be
really happy he's like rich and he's
like powerful and stuff and you think of
it in those broad brush strokes but if
but like Mark Zuckerberg and everyone
else is living in a single Pixel they
wake up they like have breakfast I go to
the gym do some work come home hang out
with the kids maybe see some friends
like that is the day today yeah and it's
very easy for us to to imagine that
happiness is found in the in the in the
whole picture in like like oh I'll be
this successful and I'll be doing this
kind of job but actually every single
day day to day we're going to be living
in the pixels and so we shouldn't over
index on what the broader picture looks
like but actually try and think about
what you know he says exactly the thing
what are the feelings we want to have in
the pixel yeah I love that and it's so
interesting because when we think about
the pixel as well I think it also links
to this broader idea of almost the
pressure to be successful as well and
thinking that that's going to make us
happy and I think it's really worthwhile
to have big goals and like having
something that you're good at is amazing
but when you think about people like
Mark Zuckerberg or whoever you want to
have in mind
um they're not going through life
thinking every second of their Waking
Life I'm so successful I'm so successful
my life is perfect Mark Zuckerberg like
you talk about that day and all I could
think about was like oh yeah then you
probably got a parking fight or he
burned his eggs in the morning or yeah
the person who makes them for him did
like oh you know his kids were really
was screaming and he had an argument
with his wife like I think that the
thing that also links to this quarter
life crisis is this idea that the
decisions that we make now are going to
be the sole reason for our happiness in
the future and the Soul determinant of
our happiness like the soul determinant
of our happiness in the future and that
is not the case because your life is
going to go a million different
directions in a blink of an eye so many
things are going to happen and I think
it's this huge myth that I don't know
where it came from that that we need to
know what we're doing in our 20s and the
life we create in this decade is somehow
going to contribute to
you know our overall happiness in in the
rest of our lives like I I think that
you're allowed to treat your life as if
it's a discreet moment every moment is a
discreet moment every decade is a
discreet decade the decisions you make
in your 20s yes some of them will bleed
on if you decide to go to medical school
you're in debt that's a lot of hours
spent right but also you can change at
any point you can change your life you
can change what you want to be doing and
what the meaning of Happiness kind of
means for you as well
um
so still on that note it sounded like
we we we we talked earlier about the
there's almost these two different
narratives that we have about our 20s
one narrative is
it's your 20s it's for exploration like
you know it's all good and the other
narrative is actually your 20 is this
for building up some kind of structure
and for getting ahead in your career and
for starting to grow your income Because
by the time you're in your 30s and you
settle down and start having kids you'll
be really glad that you actually grinded
in your 20s which unlocks more freedom
and more autonomy and more like ability
to spend time with your kids whereas if
you screwed around in your 20s now
you're 30 and working in an entry-level
job and getting home at 8pm and unable
to spend time with your kids because you
haven't enough money kind of stuff yeah
and both of those seem fairly compelling
to me like I know it's hard right how do
you how do you think about this so I
think that you can have both and I know
it's really hard to say that but you
know I had a nine to five job up until
very recently and
I I think that we have this very because
I get both right because I get the idea
of being like I want to ensure my future
is one that is secure and all of those
things but then I also want to have fun
and it's such a self-limiting belief to
think that it's an either it's it's kind
of black and white right like either you
choose this path or you choose the other
there are so many moments in the day
that are yours to create and yours to
make good and for you to create memories
in those and you can pursue Financial
Security you can pursue the beginnings
of a very fruitful career while still
allowing yourself time to take risks
still allowing yourself time to go and
explore and to travel and I think it's
all about this balance and also
consistency so I'm going to give a
personal anecdote here because I really
could only speak to my experience but I
finished uni I went straight into
consulting which I feel like a lot of
people do right Consulting with this
very broad stroke career idea it was
very structured I was like I can do this
and for a while there I was like all
right this is the path that we've chosen
I'm gonna start saving money I want a
house by the time I'm 27 so that I can
set up for my future and I did that for
a while but at the same time I was doing
my podcast right on the side and I was
using some of those extra hours that we
get in a day to feed into my creativity
and to take a bit of a risks and do
something that I enjoyed and slowly but
surely that actually begun to overtake
the nine to five so it's about achieving
balance by allowing yourself time to
pursue the other things if you've
decided that your nine to five or your
career as your main focus
um where does where does your life fit
in with that when I say life I mean like
the important things about life I mean
where do your friends sit in what are
your memories sitting what is your
family sitting what is love sitting
where does all those beautiful joyful
things fit into that equation or if
you're someone who is like I'm gonna go
and travel I'm going to go and
experience the world I think it's you
got to understand that at some point
there will be some responsibilities that
are going to come up that might
jeopardize that you don't need to think
about them now but just have like a
vague idea of what that is and maybe do
some things in that time around your
traveling to set up for the future like
go and get a diploma or get some make a
tangible investment in your future self
so maybe that's setting up
um some kind of
I don't know I don't do investing so I'm
not going to give Financial advice but
maybe like set up a portfolio or
something like that
um or invest in your education or invest
in some kind of unique skill that you
can bring to the table that when you
decide maybe it's time to settle down
you have that to fall back on right I
think it's this balance you don't have
to you don't have to choose one or the
other and that's it for the rest of your
life
how does that sit with you because I
know that you you were a doctor right
yeah and then you decided to do
something else yeah yeah I think I
broadly Vibe with the idea of balance
and I
I've always regret I've always rejected
the kind of black or white thinking yeah
like even at Medical School like when I
started diving into productivity and
psychology of like achievement and
motivation and success and stuff I would
come across things that were like
um lionizing discipline and hard work
and work ethic and there's a quote from
Muhammad Ali where he says something
like
um you know I hated every minute of
training but I said don't quit suffer
now and live the rest of your life as a
champion yeah I thought like that that
doesn't seem like a particularly fun way
to spend my University years like
suffering for the sake of I don't know a
fancier number on the certificate at the
end of it like it's gonna be a doctor at
the end of it right and so the way I
approached University and I guess
continue to approach life is by thinking
how can I work towards the things that I
care about with like growth and you know
after reading the four-hour work week
financial Independence became very
important to me how can I work towards
those things that I think I value but
how can I also enjoy every step of the
journey along the way yeah because
I have you know every everyone I've ever
spoken to who has achieved anything
major has said that the achievement
itself is hollow and it's really just
the journey that you know as Miley Cyrus
says it's the climb it's just all about
the climb and if the climb is fun then
it like the the destination is Almost
Doesn't Matter it matters only insofar
as it gives you something it gives you a
direction to head in yeah and as you hit
Milestones along the way great now your
identity changes if you stop making you
know the 3K a month then you become the
sort of person that could push for five
push for ten push for yeah 50 aren't
really like whatever those numbers might
be as you work more and more towards
them your skills and your identity
identity changes so I'm just all about
trying to enjoy the journey as much as
possible while also working towards some
sort of destination I love that and I
think that's a really healthy way of
thinking thinking about things right and
I always say that on my show but life is
going to go forward life is going to
move on
regardless of the decision that you make
but what's going to matter is whether
you're happy with that decision or
you're miserable because those hours are
still going to occur those days are
still going to happen but when you
imagine yourself in those days when you
imagine yourself in those years are you
going to be happy
are you actually going to be satisfied
with your life and if the answer is no
regardless of what decisions you're
making
then you probably should rethink it and
I think that that's very much ties in
with this idea of the journey might
sometimes be hard right but you also
need to realize and kind of adopt a bit
of an existential outlook on life which
is that you know people have different
religious beliefs but from my
perspective you really do only get one
life on this Earth
and when you're gone that's it and no
one's going to remember you and your
impact whatever that may be it's
probably going to fade away it will
inevitably fail Fade Away what matters
is is the quality of your life so and I
think that that especially relates to
people who are receiving a lot of
external pressure from family from
society to only be the amalgamation of
their successes and only be like their
personality their identity is only
linked to what they've achieved and
their actual enjoyment of life is kind
of negligent and it's it doesn't matter
so I think that's something we need to
rethink right when you talk about that
Muhammad Ali quote like that makes me
shiver because I'm like maybe I'm just
not disciplined but I would never do
something like that if like the journey
was awful but like
I got like a title at the end of it and
even then like you said sometimes that's
just as Hollow because once you've
reached that goal you kind of look
around and
think what else do I have to show for
this other than this one success this
one major dopamine Hit This One Moment
In My Life
yeah one well one question I
occasionally ask myself while journaling
is that
uh
if I were to die tomorrow would I be
reasonably happy with how I've spent the
last month
um
and if the answer to that is
you know it ever leans towards not
really then I think ah okay I need to
change something yeah because that means
that I'm not actually like I I think
that's when if I was suffering every day
in training working for something and
then I just died before the thing
happened or worse I achieved the thing
and then got depressed at the end of it
because I realized that it was it was
all Hollow I feel like that's that
that's a question that sort of cuts
through that and encourages us to enjoy
the journey as well alongside working
towards whatever goal we're working
towards yeah and I always say like
that's actually really interesting and
I'm going to start using that I was just
thinking to myself whether that whether
I am happy with the last month that I've
liked it I am actually I was like Wow
actually I think a couple months ago I
would have probably said no and I'm
really happy now but
I also think that sometimes there are
going to be like crunch periods and
periods that you're going to have to
work really hard just like awful things
are going to happen you know people pass
away things happen sickness happens
breakups happen yeah suffering happens
but it's about whether the the future
that you're imagining for yourself is
going to make up for that and going to
be worth more than that and I guess
that's also a question to ask yourself
also like consistency is key right you
can avoid some of that massive periods
of stress you know the avoidable periods
of stress right like some things just
happen and you can't avoid them but the
burnout the the hours at the library the
the hours of overtime sometimes you can
avoid that by just being consistent and
balancing both hard work and the good
things in life by building really great
habits that slowly accumulate and build
into greater productivity that's as you
talk about a lot and then also
um kind of an advantage in the sense
that you've been doing this work and not
just in these Sprints but over the long
over the long term so I also think
that's good because then you don't have
to feel like every action you take every
moment you live needs to be striving
towards this goal you know that you're
slowly improve and slowly work towards
something rather than feeling the burden
of doing it all in this moment does that
make sense yeah absolutely so I guess
like yeah we've
we've kind of talked about
um kind of defining the quarter life
crisis and all these emotions and
feelings that is very very normal to
feel these days when people are in their
20s I even know some people feeling that
in their sort of late teens who are like
oh damn I'm 16 and I really should have
figured out my life by now and it's kind
of like I was like that would you like
that as a teenager uh not really I
didn't think about things too hard I was
like that oh yeah oh my God I must have
been such a little brat like I must have
been so annoying but I was like oh my
goodness if I don't get into this
University and if I don't get perfect
grades and if I don't get a perfect atar
which for people in Australia will know
this term but it's like your final
school grade
um like my life is gonna be terrible
okay I was like that as well I didn't
admit it to myself yeah and I was like
my life is going to be terrible and it's
so funny because one of my friends took
like a completely different approach and
she was like I don't care I want to have
fun she didn't get a great final score
and she is doing amazing things she's
like the happiest person I know and I
think it just goes to show that like you
can't plan out what your life is going
to look like and you don't need to be
worried about it like oh my God if I
could go back to 16 year old me I would
just like sit her down
and just be like go to a party and and
do a bit of underage drinking like you
need to let loose here like go and run
around like you need to you need to
chill out just a little bit you don't
need to rush it's gonna be all right so
all right we're just going to take a
quick break from this episode to
introduce our sponsor which is very
excitingly heal now heal is great
because I've been a customer of Hill for
the last six years and also we've got an
interview with Julian Hearn who is the
founder of huel on this podcast so you
can check that out it'll be on the
YouTube channel and on the Spotify page
and that wasn't a fantastic master class
in entrepreneurship but anyway we're
talking about heal because heel is a
fantastically complete meal so if you're
like me and you have a fairly busy life
and you don't necessarily make the time
to shop and cook and prep and wash up
like a healthy meal at home which is
obviously ideal then the nice thing
about heel is that it's a great
alternative to an unhealthy cereal or an
unhealthy takeaway meal for example I
particularly like the heel black edition
because this is high protein and lower
carb so for 400 calories you get 40
grams of protein and so this is
absolutely fantastic for workout days
where I'm trying to get my 160 180 grams
of protein in it and it's also great
because the high protein helps me stay
full for a lot longer take my two scoops
of the Black Edition powder I like the
banana Edition and The Salted Caramel
Edition I'll mix it up in my NutriBullet
blender thing with water and maybe a
little bit of milk sometimes and then
I'll just sip on that while I'm working
my desk and that will get me the
appropriate level of protein that I need
it'll get me a decent chunk of
carbohydrates and fibers and fat and
also 26 different vitamins and minerals
which are generally very good for the
body it's also very reasonably priced
like if you work it out it comes out to
one pound 68 per meal ish which is about
400 calories and that's way cheaper than
an alternative would be if you were
ordering takeout for example so if that
sounds up your street and you would like
a nutritionally complete and affordable
and healthy option for some of your
meals then head over to heal.com forward
slash Deep dive and if you use that URL
heal.com forward slash Deep dive they
will send you a free t-shirt and also a
free shaker bottle thing with your first
order I still use my t-shirt it's great
it's a nice elastic key it fits
reasonably well it makes me look kind of
hinged so you can check that out
heel.com forward slash deep dive so
thank you so much heel for sponsoring
this episode this episode is very kindly
brought to you by trading212. now people
ask me all the time for advice about
investing because I've made a bunch of
videos about it on the YouTube channel
and my advice for most people is
generally invest in Broad stock market
index funds which is exactly what you
can do completely for free with trading
212. it's a great app that lets you
trade trade stocks and funds and ETFs
and foreign exchange if you really want
to and one of the great things about the
app is that if you're new to the world
of investing you can actually invest
with fake money you don't have to put
real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tube into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want the other
really cool feature about trading 212 is
their pies feature so what you can do is
you can follow people who've created
investing pies for example someone might
have a pie where I don't know 30 of its
apple and 20 is Tesla and 10 is the S P
500 and you can follow people on the app
and see what pies they've created and
you can see the performance of those
pies and then you can just copy and
paste a particular pie into your own
account and so that means like let's say
you've got 100 pounds to invest and
you've put 50 of it into the S P 500 but
you want to be a little bit more
experimental with the other 50 pounds
you could invest it into a pie where
someone else has generally a pro or
someone in their bedroom who just loves
the markets has already done all the
homework for you also very excitingly
there's a new feature that they've added
to the app which is a daily interest on
your uninvested cash these interest
rates may go up or down over time as the
economic environment changes but the
cool thing is that you get paid out
every single day if you're into that
sort of thing and so if you haven't yet
started with investing and you want to
give it a go then you can download the
app on the App Store and if you use the
coupon code Ali Ali at the checkout that
will give you a totally free share worth
up to 100 pounds it's available on
iPhone and Android and you can check it
out by typing in trading 212 into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading212 for sponsoring this
episode I guess we're both kind of on
the same page that really you know this
question that we're trying to answer is
like how do we navigate our 20s it's
like it's it's really all about balance
yeah and you don't want to completely
screw up your career for the sake of
chasing heroin or whatever yeah but also
you don't want to completely scrub your
your 20s by grinding all the hours at
the investment bank and not actually
having the time for anything else in
your life
um
one thing I wanted to wanted to ask you
about is
um
habits that you think kind of based on
your research and the people you've
talked to habits that are useful to
develop in your 20s so I guess when
we're thinking about how to navigate our
20s there's a few like broad categories
there is relationships there is career
there's sort of work-life balance that
kind of stuff
um there's I guess confidence finding
your true self like understanding what
what you personally Vibe with and then I
guess health is is a fifth so I wonder
if we can just kind of Blitz through
these internal I'd love to get your take
on on each of these five categories so
starting with relationships um what do
you think people struggle with most in
their 20s when it comes to relationships
oh my goodness
um I'm gonna take relationships to be
relatively broad I think we often think
about romantic Partners but I think that
our friendships are the most important
relationships that we have in our 20s
more so than any other decade you know
our early early childhood years and our
teens it's family most of us meet a
partner by in our 30s and 40s then it
becomes the partner then it becomes the
kids right but our 20s are like
friendships Galore but I think the thing
that people struggle with is have I
found the right people in my life and am
I investing in the right people in my
life and and part of that is also to do
with loneliness right and
and feeling lonely and feeling like you
don't have the right people around you
so I think like a massive habit
around that is it links to understanding
that you most people are never really
truly alone and that being lonely and
feeling alone being alone and feeling
lonely are very different things so the
thing that I do is that you need to make
plans with your friends or almost create
a schedule for yourself to spend quality
uninterrupted time with the people that
you care about at least two to three
times a week
and make that a non-negotiable not only
is it going to really improve your
mental health but additionally it's
going to kind of circum it's going to
kind of circumnavigate or avoid that
feeling that we are alone and that we're
lonely because I know that's something
that people really really struggle with
so that's like my first relationship
habit
make time for your friends and make it
tangible so that you can follow it so
two to three times a week I want like
two hours of your time devoted to
something that feeds into your
relationship needs um
I'm glad you bring this up because when
we asked in our podcast Community we you
know I said we were interviewing you and
we had more responses to that than to
anything else we've ever posted in the
podcast Community oh my God like I'm
struggling with all these things in my
20s and one of the main themes that
really came up was this feeling of
loneliness oh yeah
massive it's massive and actually there
was a study that they did recently that
showed people between the ages of 16 to
30 I think
um or maybe it was 25 to 35 basically
this period right now are now 20s
is when people experience the greatest
greatest amounts of loneliness and we
typically think that it's around you
know our people who are elderly and we
have this very outdated idea of people
sitting alone in their Flats
um Partners have died kids have moved
away and they're the lonely ones but
actually in our 20s it's such a weird
time where we do feel this overwhelming
sense of a feeling lost and B feeling
really disconnected so I think that kind
of links to my second habit that I want
to talk about which is
feel comfortable being alone and the way
that you can build this habit is much
like we devote time to our relationships
you need to create time in your week to
experience Solitude so something I do
and this is a habit that I've had to
build over time is to actually carve out
like a day each week or a night each
week where I do not talk to anyone where
I enjoy my own company where I sit with
myself in silence or I feel like the you
know from the earth just like put
something on the TV or to like be on
your phone that's not Solitude that's
not alone time you're just distracting
yourself
find time to sit with yourself and be
alone with your thoughts and engage in
something that is helpful for
understanding you and that might be a
hobby that might be journaling I'm a big
proponent of journaling and because
that's like that's just you and the page
right that's just you and the page
talking about what you want to talk
about and what's going on in your mind
and I think that is really vital for
accepting the fact that loneliness is
not your enemy and that Solitude is
actually quite sacred and so much good
stuff can come out of forcing yourself
to be alone with your own thoughts and
your feelings for even just a couple
hours a week yeah
we did an interview last season uh with
uh Francesca Specter who is the author
of a book called uh alone oh which is
all about like actually taking alone
time a bit more seriously than we do oh
I love that and since doing that
um I've kind of lost the Habit a little
bit but for for several weeks I would
occasionally do like solo dates with
myself in a new restaurant and I just I
just love going to restaurants and
Cinemas by myself it's so nice yeah I
just take a little journal with me you
know or just order whatever it's like
journal and feel good it's just such
great Vibes to do like once a week and I
find it if it's more often than that it
starts to get a bit much yeah um but the
I find that I I take that scheduling
time with friends think like super
seriously as well where
um every Tuesday night is like friends
dinner
um Sunday mornings are brunch with my
brother and my housemate um and and my
brother's wife and we invite friends
over for there so we have these two
default slots in the calendar and then
inevitably you know like Monday and
Thursday night is date night and so
Wednesday Fridays get like Often by
default filled up with creators who are
in London for the week or things like
that and so with the craziness of the
calendar I I I I often don't make that
time for alone time anymore because it
always feels like oh actually you know
this person's in town and of course I
should prioritize that I'm selfish to do
it yeah and then eventually like it I
just
after a few weeks of this I'll get to a
point where I feel like I've just been
Non-Stop and I haven't really taken the
time to reflect on on how the week's
gone or how the month has gone so I find
these sort of periods of alignment quite
quite helpful yeah self-reflection it's
a habit you've gotta you gotta build it
as well what sort of questions do you
ask yourself when journaling
um so I actually have this amazing
Journal that someone sent me from oh my
gosh I want to say Scotland and each
week it has these each day actually it
poses a little question so the journal
structure is what are my goals for
tomorrow
um what's list like 10 things that
you're grateful for today
um and that's another habit that we're
going to talk about in a second and then
it will be like um what what is one song
that represents how you're feeling right
now oh or
um what is one small thing in your life
right now that you could change and
you'd be happier for it or what is one
one goal that if someone said you could
have this right now you would want it's
like those little things that make you
really think about
um make you really think about where you
sit with yourself and your values and
and all of those things and then if I
just like free Journal I'll just write
about whatever's on my mind
um normally how I'm feeling like I've
had a rough day or
um you know I went through a breakup
like a year ago and oh my goodness
reading back over that was also a lot
but it's all about processing your own
emotions and not needing other people to
validate or reinforce how you feel
because you are the most important
relationship that you're ever going to
have and the others contribute to that
but if that relationship isn't steady if
you don't know yourself well enough it
everything else is going to be formed on
a rocky Foundation
um yeah I love that one one thing I
enjoy doing is collecting journaling
prompts oh cool there's a bunch of
people I follow on Twitter like just
enjoy journaling as well and when I see
a prompt I'm like oh that's a great
question oh because I think there's just
something to the power of asking
yourself and other people powerful
questions Yeah because sometimes if I
ask myself what's on my mind I'm just
like uh I I it's it's hard to
really answer that properly but if I ask
myself something like
what's one thing what's one thing I did
today that if I or or if I ask myself
that if I repeated everything I did
today would I be closer to where I want
to be or further away from where I want
to be oh my God and then that reminds me
oh that's interesting I actually haven't
I actually didn't go to the gym today
and so if I repeat it every single day
if I repeat it today for the next year
I'd probably be in pretty bad shape cool
I didn't call my mum or my grandma today
that's something I should change it and
it just like prompts those sorts of
things which otherwise if I just ask
myself what's on my mind or open up
Journal those thoughts wouldn't have
come out yeah
I really like that now when we're in the
school or university friendship Galore
like you live next to people
everything's all good so fun but then
people graduate they get jobs friends
move away everyone gets busy
and it seems like even if you're living
in the same city like I'm now living in
London like literally all of my friends
with the exception of a handful of uh
friends who are doctors who have moved
to different parts of the world
um all my friends are in London and yet
it still feels like I see my school
friends once every six months once a
year because even though they were in
London just sort of getting the
calendars to line up and schedules to
line up and all that kind of stuff plus
the fact that it usually needs one
person to take the initiative and if
everyone's busy does that have you got
any tips or best practices or habits for
um maintaining or building new
friendships close to University yes so
I'm gonna I'm gonna offer you two here
perfect the first one is around those
pre-existing relationships I truly
believe that you should be the person to
take initiative
if you want something if you want to see
these people if those relationships are
kind of falling apart like
be the person be the person who takes
initiative it can take a lot of energy
but I'm that person in in my friendship
groups and I'll do things like let's one
of them is I do a Sunday dinner so every
Sunday when I'm in town I say to anyone
who lives in Sydney who I know come for
dinner
just bring a bottle of wine bring
dessert bring something and have a feed
and just let me know like four hours in
advance if you're coming along bring
Partners bring anyone and that Sunday
dinner is actually such like is like the
glue for some of my relationships and
not to say that like those people are
only coming for the free food but
they're so busy that having a discreet
day where I know that we're going to see
each other actually is a lot easier for
a lot of people to navigate with such
busy lives
um so that's actually a a tip I wouldn't
say a habit but a tip if you can afford
to do it if you have the time make the
initiative something like a Sunday
dinner or like a Saturday brunch Club is
like a great kind of activity to bring
people together and the the other habit
that I think is really important is to
be consistent in your hobbies and your
activities if you're looking to make new
friends so I think this applies to a lot
of people in their 20s I moved to a new
city
um like almost two years years ago a
year and a half ago and I left behind
this whole community that I had and I
felt like I was starting from scratch
and the best thing that I did was invest
time in consistently going to the same
activities and the same Hobbies week in
week out and those were cycling classes
and rock climbing
when you go to the same location and do
the same thing in the same building
it's likely that the same people are
going to be there and it's likely that
you already have something in common
that you can Bond over and similarity we
know is the biggest biggest determinant
of friendship similarity and proximity
and then reciprocity so you kind of
already have those two down right
similarity you're doing an activity that
you know the people in that room already
like and proximity you're going to see
these people week and week out if they
also are showing up consistently at the
activities that you're doing I made so
many friends that way because you start
to become familiar faces in each other's
lives you strike up a conversation next
thing you know are you coming next week
yeah I am we should get a coffee
beforehand boom friendship nice that's a
that's a really big habit that I and a
habit but also a tip that I think is so
valuable if you want to make new friends
is to show up in the same places at the
same time and I'm sure that the people
that you'll actually find yourself
really being aligned to will be the
people who are doing the same thing
does that make sense yeah that's such a
good idea yeah yeah I think like
I feel like one of the one of the one of
the things about University and why
people often end up making friends with
the people that they live next to it's
just that proximity thing and it's less
about quality time and more about
quantity time oh yeah and so showing up
to the same activity like I started
kickboxing lessons a few months ago but
I really half-assed it and I haven't
shown up to the group classes
consistently and therefore there's no
chance I'm gonna make friends with
anyone there but if I just showed up for
like a few weeks in a row chances are I
would have made friends with at least
one person there and like you know they
go to the pub afterwards and you join
them and then that's how friendships are
formed whereas oh I'm so I'm too busy
this week because work and I'm too busy
that week because work I don't know to
be that because I've got other plans now
it makes it a lot harder to make friends
in that specific setting yeah well the
other one that's really good is um
sports games so like sports games
I do that sounds so naive but matches
but uh sports team so like I joined my
football team like a football team that
was great what team a Futsal sucks
indoor soccer yeah it's indoor soccer in
Australia oh cool do you guys don't have
that here I mean we call it the indoor
football but yeah we don't have a proper
name for it yeah so we don't have a
football no you call it soccer yeah
soccer indoor soccer so that was great
and I also think another habit it that
it's also a line to this idea of making
friends
um that I think anyone needs to form
whether you are in your teens or your
20s or your 30s that is active listening
active listening is such an attractive
quality in any friend any partner any
workmate any acquaintance so you want to
possess that as well and I think that
it's a skill that takes time so
practicing actually
listening to what people are saying
acknowledging how their body is reacting
to you
trying to and it comes naturally over
time I think we're actually not
inherently great listeners this in this
generation because
we're so bombarded by all the stimulus
and all these things going on in our
brain and in our environment that
sometimes these kinds of conversations
the one that we're having right now
um Can it can be very hard to engage in
them so practice active listening
practice actually making eye contact
with someone trying to imagine what
their what they're feeling what they're
thinking and engage with what they're
saying to you and reciprocate that I
think that when we talk about
relationships in our 20s whatever that
may be being an active listener makes
you
um an attractive person to have a
relationship relationship with someone
who's enjoyable to be around and it just
causes all of our relationships to
flourish
any tips for active listening
um so I I think that I realized that I
wasn't a great active listener and
um someone gave me this tip was to
really look at okay I'm Gonna Act well
you're not talking but I'm going to
pretend that I'm active listening to you
right now is to really like look at
someone and be and and really try and
sit in their words and picture their
words and imagine what they're saying so
instead of just being like oh this is
just stuff that's coming into my ear
like really imagine that you're in their
stories with them and that visualization
will it will make you more engaged a but
it will make you seem more engaged
because you are
um the other thing to do I think active
listening is not just about what's
coming out verbally it's also about
someone's body and really taking time to
acknowledge okay I we all kind of
understand various body cues actually
recognize them and pick up on how's this
person feeling and can I make them more
comfortable or how am I acting right now
and is that making them uncomfortable or
is it making them feel safe so all of
those two kind of things to to
understand and to get further into what
someone else is telling you I think is
important and it is just a skill I think
yeah one one uh one thing I was
researching for my book was you know
what are the differences between
energizing relationships and training
relationships I love this concept and
one of the key things that came up in in
the in the studies that I was looking at
was
um
the idea of energizing responses
so for example if someone shares news
then there's sort of four different ways
to respond to that and the two main axes
for that are is it active or passive and
is it constructive or destructive so
active constructive is where we kind of
want to be for the most energizing
relationships which is you know you you
say you've just run a half marathon or
whatever and an active constructive
response might be oh my God that's
incredible tell me more about how did it
feel and it's like I'm building on it
and asking you to share more that's so
good a passive constructive response
would be oh that's cool yeah passive I
mean it's constructive in that I haven't
like torn you down for it but yeah it's
not that energizing it's sort of neutral
at best a passive destructive response
would be
um kind of
oh cool but let me tell you about the
thing that I did where it's like kind of
the self-center thing and then an active
destructive response is a total dick
whereas someone's like well that's not
such a big deal like blah blah blah blah
like why would you think you should do
that you're going to ruin your knees
that would just be a completely
unhelpful response yeah and shifting
more towards energizing interactions
active constructive responses to things
there's like genuine evidence from like
psychology studies that people who do
that are seen as more energizing more
charismatic more enjoyable to be around
than people that respond in any of the
other three ways it's so powerful isn't
it it's um the one that you said uh it's
active no passive constructive is that
it where someone's like oh that's cool
yeah
isn't that the worst
I honestly think that that's worse than
someone being like oh cool but guess
what I did I like and especially when
you share news with with friends or
family and I think those are the people
that we love the most and we trust the
most and we want them to be like really
in our corner but then you have to
remember that
the reaction that you want from someone
else you need to give them as well so
anytime someone gives you really great
news like you need like you should be
genuinely excited for them if they're
someone that you care about or someone
that you like or someone that you know I
think that's so valuable just
reciprocating yeah good energy from the
people that you want in your life is so
powerful in our ways
yeah the other the other tip that um one
of our team members actually shared with
me uh was you know something he's fun
really helpful is just a greeting
someone very effusively because if like
we hang out with a friend like I think
especially as dudes um I suspect it's
like you're kind of trying to play cool
like oh really you don't want to be too
keen and you don't want to come across
as like you know a bit too kind of
emotionally expressive and so you're
just like oh hey man how's it going
whereas like if I like oh my God God
went it's so good to see you it's been
so long like how are you like just
something like that makes the other
person feel great makes you feel great
starts the interaction off on the right
foot like and it's a very easy hack just
like greeting people more effusively
than you think you should
um really helps to again make
relationships more energizing yeah and I
think sometimes think people think that
that's inauthentic and I don't think
that's the case
um I think it's just about tapping into
how you really feel about someone and
it's almost like adopting like a
labrador philosophy of like oh my God
I'm so excited to see this person and
even if you you don't like you know you
have those days be like I'm so tired I'm
so tired and I really wanted to cancel
these plans but I haven't seen this
person in six months and a lot of it is
about like faking it till you make it if
you like a really if you're actually
excited to see someone you will feel
excited to see them and they'll feel
excited to see you and then it's like an
amazing positive experience so I really
did believe in in that advice that you
just gave absolutely fake it till you
make it fake it till you make it
diffusively how do you think about
setting boundaries in relationships oh I
I really believe in this and I do think
that it's become a bit of a therapy like
a therapized idea obviously it's based
in therapy but there's so much dialogue
about this online rhetoric about
boundary setting online I think it's
become a bit misconstrued but our 20s
are really a great time to learn how to
set healthy boundaries and when I say
healthy I mean respectful for yourself
but also respectful of others sometimes
we think okay I need to set a boundary
and that means that I'm just gonna fully
cut this person off and that's it that's
not healthy that's not mature
um I think a massive
habit around setting boundaries is to do
with really understanding what you want
out of your relationships I think
another part of that is really
understanding how our people-pleasing
Tendencies really feed into the
relationships we have so the habit that
I think that we need to set the thing
that we need to get better at in this
generation is a understanding what we
want from our relationships and the
behavior that we won't accept and be
learning how to
communicate that to people without being
worried about hurting their feelings and
I don't think that there is one specific
way that we can go about this I think
there are many ways that people arrive
at this point and often it comes from
really horrible experiences like have
you had this experience where you
haven't set a boundary until it's way
too late yep and then you're like oh my
God I wish that I had done this sooner
and I would have avoided my avoided so
much pain and someone said this to me
the other day but the most compassionate
people have the best boundaries
and I just think that is
so so spot on
like what's an example in your life
where you've set a boundary and it's
been helpful
um
I think a massive habit around that is
getting used to being vulnerable and
being honest with the people in your
life so I have this example from when I
moved to Sydney
that really shook up a lot of my
relationships I went to University in
Canberra which is the capital of
Australia and I left all of my really
good friends behind
that put our relationship long distance
friendships that puts your relationship
under a lot of strain
and I had this I wouldn't say problem
this is one of my closest friends it's
never a problem that can't be solved
there really isn't any problems but I
think this friction and this confusion
around how much time I was going to be
able to devote to coming back to see
this person or coming back to or to
calling them all the time or always
replying to their messages right like I
had this new life that I was trying to
invest in I really respected her but
there was this friction occurring where
I couldn't maintain both right I
couldn't come back every weekend I was
trying to create a new life so what I
started trying to do was to build up
honesty with her and it was honesty in
the sense of just being honest about
what was going on in my life and then
slowly building up to being honest about
the state of our relationship and
honesty is itself a boundary right
because in honesty we communicate what
we want so what I ended up doing was
the bound when I wanted to set a
boundary I gave her an option
so I would say for example it was her
birthday actually recently and I would
say okay your birthday is is on this
weekend you want me to come down for two
nights
um I actually can't do that because I'm
I've got a lot going on with work which
night would you like me to choose which
night would you like me to come down and
it's about being honest yes but also
setting boundaries and being willing to
compromise
um I think that's the healthiest version
of a boundary that you can come to
you've got to remember that boundaries
aren't just around making sure
everything goes your way
life is really like relationships in
life are really complicated you're gonna
have to compromise sometimes
um but if you have good boundaries that
are respectful and that are you're
willing to be somewhat flexible on
I think that makes them a lot more
robust
so we've talked a little bit about
relationships let's talk about careers
now we talked about that whole
navigating that like travel the world
and find yourself versus grind and
hustle in your 20s and you just kind of
said that it's important to get a bit of
a little bit of a balance
but I guess with that with that in mind
that balance is what we're trying to go
for here um what are some habits that
you think are helpful to develop in your
20s yeah I think career is a big thing
on our minds right
um especially in our 20s as we talked
about throughout all of this but the
first habit I think that you need to
kind of cultivate is stepping out of
your comfort zone
I think that there is a saying that I
love when it comes to this which is that
you can either choose to be comfortable
or you can choose to grow and our 20s
are an amazing point where we can we can
we can grow and we have the
opportunities and we have the freedom to
kind of push the limits of what we think
is possible so we don't know most of us
wouldn't have kids in our early 20s most
of us wouldn't have a mortgage I would
assume wouldn't be married
um those are like three massive
responsibilities and once those come
into play it's a lot harder to take a
risk in your career or step out of your
comfort zone big or small so using that
that time and especially in our early
20s to capitalize on that opportunity is
so valuable and what that could look
like is going back to University if
there's something that's really
captivated your attention going and
getting a diploma I know that's easier
said than done in Australia it's free
you get a loan from the government so
I'm sure there's people listening out
there who don't have that Financial
opportunity and don't have the ability
to do that but also um stepping out of
your comfort zone means applying for
jobs that like are just a little bit
above where you think you currently are
asking for promotions those kinds of
things really most of the time if you
apply for like if you apply for a job
that's a little bit above where you
currently sit you'll probably get it and
yeah there'll be a couple of months
where you're kind of learning the ropes
but that's going to really put you in
good stead for the future maybe at that
company but also in your career as well
hmm yeah on that note there was a good
start I think it was from the book lean
in by Cheryl Sandberg
so good um where she said something like
um
when women look at a job description uh
they think they're suited if they match
100 of the requirements when men look at
a job description they think they're
suited if they match 60 of the
requirements
and it's just such a big gap in like how
seriously people take job descriptions
and like job requirements and stuff but
also how willing or unwilling certain
people are to
put themselves in that position of
uncomfortableness or even just like
backing themselves that like yeah I got
this how hard can it be yeah and I think
that women are naturally taught to feel
a little bit smaller when it comes to
those things and
um I think and naturally obviously we've
been in the workforce for a while but
yeah there is still that expectation of
like oh I don't want to be like I don't
want to be the reason why some some
stereotype is met so I want to make sure
that I really am really aligned to what
is expected of me that's not all women
but I would say like that example that
that um that lean in gave that book gave
is like super spot on hmm
any tips on that front like if if there
are women listening to this who are
struggling with this career thing and
seeing their male colleagues like be
more bullish for promotions and stuff
like that and they're like
I'm kind of doing a good job in like no
one's no one's noticing my input
yeah
um lean in no
um this is gonna maybe come off a bit
strange but be rude you can be rude ask
for what you want because most of the
time when women are rude it comes off as
normal
um I think that women's like when we
think of rude we think that it's really
like you know I have so many friends who
are like oh was that rude like was what
I said rude and I'm like absolutely not
it's just that I think as a gender we
can be quite people pleasing so as a tip
just ask for it be rude push back if
someone keeps interrupting you
keeps keep talking until they get the
message don't let them cut you off
um say your piece I think also put your
hand up and if you think that you have
something really valuable to share you
should share it it's not rude you're not
you're not being aggressive you're just
doing your job and you're just taking up
the space that you deserve to take up
and
um I think when it comes to Promotions
you don't have to be like oh my male
colleagues are getting promoted and make
it about gender if you don't want to
sometimes that is true sometimes it's
not but if you have a reasonable case
for being like I should receive this
promotion
that's that's your duty to do that like
you you should respect yourself enough
to go into your manager's office or the
HR office and make your case it's not
rude you're not being aggressive you're
just self-assured and you know your
worth and I think that's something that
I think men and women kind of have to
learn especially younger people have to
learn
um that no one's taking anything
personally here yeah you've just got to
do what's best for yourself
yeah I guess it's it's very easy to
think that
oh if if I do a good job my manager says
it's just going to notice and of course
I'm going to get the promotion like yeah
how do you Contour that yeah yeah I
don't think that's true and I think that
um it kind of depends what company
you're working in right I used to work
at a fairly large company
um there wasn't much oversight over that
and I think sometimes companies do this
thing where they have like I don't know
you're you're a doctor you kind of
become a doctor and is there a promo is
there a level above that like yeah
there's like some very very specific
yeah tick boxes things to go up the
ladder exactly and that was kind of what
it was like in my old firm and you've
got to kind of realize that you know
everyone is watching your behavior every
minute so although you may think that
you're doing really really well
unless you actually
put that image out there and say okay
this is what I've been doing I deserve a
promotion people are often not going to
see it because there's this weird thing
where people only tend to notice
behavior when it's not good behavior
when it's negative or when you like mess
up and all the good stuff kind of flows
under the radar so bring that to their
attention
um and it's like I said it's not rude
it's just your job you're doing your job
well yeah and it kind of links to my to
my next tip that I'm going to give you
but
um if you're doing your job really well
if you're going above and beyond you
deserve to be paid more I just think
that's that's the case in most
situations yeah we were talking about
this audio are you so you said yeah act
your wage yeah what do you mean by that
this is my next big habit that's a hot
take because I think I disagree with
this but I'd love to hear what I don't
want your viewers I'm so excited to talk
about it because I do think it's a
little bit um controversial sometimes
when I say this but act your wage is
basically it's kind of like actual age
and I don't know where I saw it but
actual wage is like if you're getting
paid a certain amount
you you shouldn't be too flexible with
the duties that you're doing above that
because you're not getting paid for
those and especially when you when I
talk about things like overtime and a
lot of in Australia at least I think a
lot of places you don't get paid for
overtime
um that's your time that's your life you
should value that time as much as your
employer values your time so it's about
realizing what am I actually getting
paid for here and how much am I willing
to go over that and give more to this
company because like at the end of the
day it's just a job it's not your life
but what do you think because I know you
have a different and I know there is
different opinions here yeah I agree
that
I think I think it depends on what you
want so I think I I fully agree with the
sentiment that your time is
fundamentally the most the world the
most valuable resource that you have and
you shouldn't give that time away
lightly and similarly I agree that
basically every job is put just a job at
the end of the day and shouldn't come at
the expense of your life
but I think I would say it's less actual
wage and more act uh act the wage you
actually want
and I think that specially applies
because I have a team of 15 people in
his very startup mode where if someone
is acting way above their wage then
I will notice that yeah if someone's
doing their job I won't really notice
that until they kind of unless they like
tell me and show me what they're doing
and I agree like even even with a small
team
everyone is just busy with everything
and so no one really has the time to
have fundamental oversight on whatever
what everyone else is doing and so you
know one thing that some of our team
members do is at the end of every week
they'll just create a little loom video
recording of like here's the stuff I
worked on this week here are the
interesting Salient insights and it's so
easy for me to watch that at three times
speed and think [__] that person's doing
an amazing job yeah whereas the people
that don't do that it's very like they
do fantastic work but it's very easy for
that work to fly under the radar because
it's just not that visible to me because
like I'm just not poking around on Ocean
pages and trying to see what everyone
else is up to and all this all this kind
of stuff so there's there's easy ways of
like
showing the boss or the manager or
something what you're doing because and
just that just brings the top of mind
but I think also in startup land
and I've I've got a bunch of friends who
are like sort of uh have their own sort
of companies with like five to 25-ish
employees and it's really obvious who
the star players are and the star
players are the ones that you really
fight hard to keep keep hold of except
to keep hold of yeah and if they wanted
to leave and start their own things
those star players are the ones that you
would be giving the most glowing
recommendations and like genuinely
throwing all the clients their way if
they want to become Freelancers etc etc
and that doesn't come from acting your
wage it comes from acting way above your
wage and delivering at higher than the
rate that the employer is paying you
yeah and so there's kind of this
Balancing Act of if you value getting a
quote getting ahead in that career
and the environment is set up to
to recognize that then acting above your
wages actually a good strategy but if
you're in a corporate environment like
in medicine acting above your way it
doesn't do anything it's actually
actively unhelpful yeah because you just
physically cannot progress because you
have to take certain exams and you have
to be at a certain stage to take the
certain exam so actually acting above
your wage in medicine and above above
your station is just likely to get you
sued because you know it's your senior
that needs to take responsibility for
the specific thing rather than you as
the junior but I think in a lot of
smaller smaller companies that's less
the case
that's actually so interesting because
you said something there that I want to
grab and that is if the environment is
right
I don't think that the environment is is
right in most cases and I don't think
that it will be recognized unless you've
explicitly pointed out and so if you're
willing to point it out if you are
willing to make those videos as you were
talking about and call attention to that
you're doing more I think that's really
valuable but I also think that you can
still do your job incredibly well and
you can be incredibly productive and
Innovative and creative within the hours
that you're getting paid for and
anything more than that you kind of have
to be happy with the fact that as we
said I think we said this way before is
it worth it is the time you're giving up
worth it for the payoff and
um it's interesting when you talk about
the the startup the startup space and
the entrepreneurial space it's like all
those people are going to be the ones
that are going to get the clothing
recommendations and that's really great
they can make or break a career right
but are they going to be getting paid
more to do that and I also think that
that space is very
um very one-of-a-kind
um compared to a lot of other a lot of
other Industries and a lot of other
business models and a lot of other
um yeah Industries and sectors so in
general I would say that acting your
wage is going to make you happier and
allow you to actually have work-life
balance better than acting above your
wage but I do really like what you were
saying around
um it for your career it can kind of
make or break and if you are acting for
act the wage that you want if the
conditions that you're working in allow
for that to be recognized it's very
interesting right absolutely
um I think yeah there's a a couple of
points on that one is that
um
and one of the piece of advice pieces of
advice I've often heard from
entrepreneurs is that if you want to
become an entrepreneur do not join a
corporate join a small small business
instead small join a small business that
has fewer than 10 employees because that
will train you in business in a way that
joining a big corporate will never do
the Consultants will say of course
you'll learn about how to run a business
when you join McKinsey but like [__]
you learn how to do PowerPoint slides
and Excel models on BS that is not even
relevant 50 years from now
um whereas if you if you join a small
company even if it's like a local
accounting firm that has like eight
people in it you have so much visibility
over everything that goes on in that
business so that when you if you do want
to start your own business someday that
is a fantastic training ground yeah I
totally agree with you and it's
interesting you gave the the tax the
accounting example
starting your own business oh my God I
worked at I worked in Consulting I made
so many PowerPoint slides I did so much
stuff like that and the thing that was
like so interesting is that I quit and I
have no idea what anything about tax or
how to balance my money sheets or how to
budget or like how to handle my finances
when it comes to my business and like I
think that's such a good point like if
you if you want to excel start small and
that means start small within a company
uh start small within the skills you're
learning but also starts more within the
kind of employer and that kind of links
to the next part that I want to talk
about for a tip in your 20s which is job
hunt and job hop as much as possible
I think that this is as long as you
leave on on good terms with your
previous employer you need to be taking
as many risks and looking into as many
Industries and as many possibilities as
possible very rarely will the first
thing we do straight out of the gate
straight out of uni be the thing that
makes us happy and be the thing that's
going to fulfill us so the only way to
sometimes realize that is to find
something else to do and it can be super
random so like I used to work I've job
hop so much I was Notorious for I used
to work in
um on the phone for donations for like
Charities
um then I was a data analyst and I did
like data work and then I worked for a
long time in um not a long time but for
a while in child maltreatment and
domestic violence and then I went and
did mental health policy and now I'm
doing a podcast and I learned so much
from all those things that have
contributed so beautifully to what I
love and what I'm doing now but it also
allowed me to never feel like I was
wasting time because I was always doing
something that kept me engaged and that
I could learn from what do you think
about that do you think it's better to
to invest in stay at one place and
really climb the ranks and learn as much
as you can from there or to seek new
opportunities as soon as you've kind of
drained that previous Source or you've
learned what you need to learn yeah I
think I'm with you on this one if it
feels kind of weird to say because I
don't want my team to leave me um
because they're great
um but it is broadly in an individual's
better interest to job hop than it is to
stay in one place yeah yeah unless that
one places absolute rocket ship and you
know that there's like way more
responsibility coming coming into the
business and therefore like you actually
do change your own role quite a lot I
think actually yeah I think it's less
about changing jobs and more about
changing roles yeah that's a really good
point and often changing roles will mean
changing jobs if it's a very rigid thing
yeah but within a startup changing roles
it's like if the startup is growing
there's always more demand for jobs jobs
to be done than there are people to do
them whereas if the company is declining
then there are always more people than
there are jobs and so that's a real a
real problem
um but I think yeah like the first six
six months so 12 months probably at a
job are the fastest learning curve and
then beyond that you really Plateau out
unless you switch all at that point and
so if I were giving advice in the best
interest of the team members I don't
want to leave me I would say you should
probably start looking for another job
because a the best way to get a raise is
but by just finding another job oh yeah
leverage that leverage that um but also
the best way to learn more skills is
finding another job yeah where you get
paid to learn rather than earn kind of
vibe just do and I love that part as
well um my housemate God bless him Tom
hey I hope he doesn't mind me sharing
this I'm sure he wouldn't mind he does
this a lot uh not a lot but he really
taught me this power of leveraging other
job opportunities to get promotions and
he is really good at it because he'll
he's very self-aware of like all right
I've learned what I needed to learn at
this level I need more responsibility
and he's a he's such a go-getter and
he's so motivated
um and sometimes the company he works at
doesn't really allow him to to grow
they're a very rigid company yeah so
he'll go out and he's so talented and so
good at his job that he'll be like okay
I've got this offer from Qantas or I've
got this offer from some big company
he'll and he'll leverage it and get a
higher position and so I think it's the
same thing about what you said before
it's not about Job hopping because
that's going to be really stressful and
around your finances and all those
things but roll hopping as well just
take as many risks as possible just
learn so much
um it also I feel like the worst the
worst feeling to have is to hit like 35
and be like oh [__] like I'm still doing
the same thing I was doing at 22 and now
I want to change but I feel like I've
aged out of the time that I had to to
switch to switch around and of course as
you can start at any age you can change
at any age but in our 20s I think it's a
lot easier to do that
yeah no great I think equally like
there's uh one of our team members uh
Alison has like a completely complete
opposite take on this um so she spent
three years working her way up an
accounting firm and got the tax
qualifications and all that stuff in
Ireland and then decided to move to
London for this job to work on our team
and her whole thing is you know for the
first time in my life I am not going to
strive and I'm not going to grind I'm in
my 20s I'm gonna enjoy my 20s I'm gonna
you know I'm doing this job because it's
it's fun and interesting and it's just a
job but I'm not trying to side hustle on
the weekends I'm not trying to side
hustle in the evenings I want to see
every musical that London has to offer I
want to hang out with my friends every
day I want to play rugby like I want to
live my best life and I in this phase of
life I don't want to strive I love Alice
and Alison says that she's the happiest
person she knows so like yeah I think
for some people that making the
intentional and active decision to
actually just be happy in a job that you
that you enjoy enough to get on with and
then quote enjoy the rest of your life
outside of that is also a reasonable
strategy that and I think as long as
you're not going to regret it when
you're older then you you do you my best
friend Aaron um she has the same
philosophy which she's like I'm actually
she's she's very similar to Allison
she's like my career is actually not my
life
I do not live to work yeah I just work
to live and the things that and all that
work does is give me a paycheck so I can
go and do my hobbies she's also one like
she's also one of the most well-balanced
people that I know and like she really
doesn't dream of Labor and I love her
for that and her and her partner
um go like Tasmania is this island off
of Australia it's like beautiful and
um it's like half of it is like
basically nature like it's a national
park
um and they like go out and they do
hikes and they go and volunteer and
plant native bulbs and they save
wildlife and I'm like you guys have the
best life and it all comes from that
philosophy of
after wage be balanced but also don't be
afraid to take some risks if it's going
to lead to Greater balance and happiness
and what you want to do
okay so we kind of touched on the idea
of work-life balance but I wonder if
you've got any specific habits that you
would recommend for people in their 20s
to navigate the idea of work-life
balance or work-life integration or
however you want to think about it yeah
I've got this really amazing activity
kind of that I do well I did when I
worked nine to five that I think is
really valuable so
when we think about our life I like to
think about in terms of five buckets and
each day you need to do something in
each of those categories so one of them
is physical so exercise moving your body
one of them is mental looking after your
mental well-being and taking care of
yourself there one of the one part of
that is practical as well so practical
meaning there's just some [__] you need
to get done you got to do your laundry
you're going to do your groceries you
got to do those things social
um so you need to feel fulfilled
socially and and to get that connection
and then the final one is uh spiritual
or emotional or to do with your hobbies
so in your day I want you if you want if
you're really you know wanting to
achieve work-life balance
try and find a way to hit everything one
of these five categories So Physical
walk to work
um mental check in with yourself at the
end of the day maybe take your
medication that you've been prescribed
do a very short five minute meditation
when you get home from work
um in terms of practical
make yourself dinner just do something
practical that's going to make your life
better the next day make your bed do
some laundry something that's going to
just make your life a little bit easier
social cool friend they don't have to be
these big massive time commitments and
then like a spiritual mental one maybe
you're religious you want to pray for a
little while or read your Bible
or whatever I'm not being I'm not a very
religious person whatever you want to do
if you want to practice your religion or
do something that like feeds your soul
so one thing I do is like I knit so when
I watch TV I'm like oh this feels like
such
like such a like it's squeezing my brain
of like the good energies and like it
just feels like such a zombie-like
activity so I've taken to like knitting
while I do it and it kind of it hits all
those five buckets and it allows you to
achieve greater work life balance
because in those hours that we have
Beyond work we we fill it in with the
things that are going to keep us feeling
healthy and keep us feeling like our
life is more than just our jobs does
that make sense does it does that
resonate with you yeah it really does I
like this fight like I I love
categorizing things into smaller numbers
than is yeah right yeah because it's
like if if you think if people are like
oh what did what do I do with my life
like life is such a big thing but it
just becomes so so much more manageable
if you split it about into three or five
or seven or nine yeah I didn't you know
fewer is better uh categories and on one
hand as well yeah yeah the way I think
of it is uh basically uh work Health
relationships but then within Health
there's uh body mind soul yeah and so I
like to keep it simple so it's just each
day I just need to take one action in
work health or relationships yeah so my
health thing today was I went for a walk
around Hyde Park my relationship thing
is I will call my grandma after this uh
work thing is drawing diagrams for my
book
um and sometimes the health thing will
be physical like going for a walk
um and sometimes it will be like mental
spiritual like practicing the guitar
which I've shoehorned into health
because it doesn't neatly fit into local
relationships
um but I think just any way of like
splitting up
life into a few different categories
that's more manageable really helps like
genuinely navigate that thing of
work-life balance because if you have
balance across work Health relationships
or however you want to split it up then
you're doing pretty all right yeah and
the other thing I would say is take
advantage of your Sundays oh okay use
your Sundays to reset and recharge don't
fill them up with like a million social
activities if you want work life balance
it's hard I wish there was a four day
work week as we were talking about
before but alas we do not have that so I
always take my Saturdays for socializing
and activities and having fun and then
my son knows for a recharge to get my
life in order do the laundry
dust I've literally never dusted I don't
know why it's gonna be like wow that's
impressive vacuum there we go
um and of course do your Sunday dinners
absolutely we're we're trialing a
nine-day fortnight in our team these
days oh how's it going uh it's good our
first official Friday off was like last
Friday um I think about half the team
actually ended up taking it off oh
that's good the other half ended up like
including me and I ended up ended up
working but it was quite nice because
there were no meetings and it was just
like a day to bash through everything
anything that needed doing and was quite
relaxing and chill so we're trying this
for the next six weeks uh yeah this was
actually Alison's idea
um she has a friend working at a startup
that does these nine day fortnights yeah
and it's more manageable than a four day
week which is quite a lot of faff and
also other people out on a four day week
yeah exactly and so like actually when
you squeeze down the amount of days
available but not a fortnight like
anything that can be done in 10 days can
also be done in nine days realistically
yeah and the things that can't are the
thing the lowest priority things that
shouldn't be done anyway so it forces in
theory forces prioritization yeah so
we're trying to get out and seeing and
seeing how it works and over time we
might have to become more Draconian
about people actually taking that Friday
off because
it's just like a deep work day then
rather than a day off which is which is
fine but yeah yeah at my old company we
have this thing called recharge days so
if you'd worked
um two two weeks or more where you'd
worked in an excess of 10 hours over
time you had to take a recharge day oh
so you had to take like a Friday or a
Monday off and that was so lovely and I
think that was really what like
encouraged me to go into
doing my own thing because I was like I
love this flexibility of having a an
extra day to myself one thing I find
really helpful for work-life balance is
um something uh called the ideal week
method oh so basically what this is is
that you go on Google Calendar or
whatever you create a brand new calendar
so it's completely blank and you call it
your ideal Week calendar and you just
block out in The week-long View
what does your audio week actually look
like or your ideal practical week so
let's say you want to wake up at seven
o'clock you would block wake up at seven
like do morning routine let's say you
you're at work from nine till five you
block that out for work and maybe you
can subdivide that and it's like ideally
depending on how much control over you
have over your schedule this is when I'd
like to do deep work this is when I'd
like to check slack an email this is
what I'd like to have meetings ideally
obviously people have different levels
of control over their own schedules and
then the evenings again you block out
like okay every Tuesday let's say in my
ideal week every Tuesday is a
I cook dinner for friends and every
Sunday dinner is also a dinner with
friends I'd say Thursday night is date
night Wednesday night is rock climbing
Monday night is my alignment time Friday
I'll just leave blank for any
spontaneous thing that comes up and
Saturdays I'll leave empty for again
spontaneous things that come up and I
want to go gym three times a week so
let's say that's Monday Wednesday Friday
you know I've already been wanting to
learn the guitar I'm like okay cool I
can squeeze that in on a Thursday I
Really Wanna Have singing lessons as
well but then you realize actually I
actually physically don't have enough
hours in my week anymore yeah you know
what what's more important singing your
guitar actually yeah let's stick to
guitar I can always put singing in later
yeah and you then map this to your
actual calendar and just try and follow
this and this is great because firstly
it gives you visibility over like it
firstly gives you intentionality over
what you actually want to spend your
time on yeah but secondly it gives you
visibility over how much time you
actually have
um and it's very easy I think especially
in our 20s and I imagine increasingly
when people have kids and over commit
like everyone feels over committed like
they're doing too many things
but what I find is whenever I need to
add I whenever I want to add a new habit
or a new recurring thing to my life like
I was thinking just this morning oh you
know I've been watching some John Mayer
videos I'd love to get back into guitar
lessons I look at the ideal week and I'm
like well where where do I want to fit
those in
nowhere it's not a priority right now
cool it'll it'll just go in the bucket
list for at some point further down the
line yeah so it's just a nice way of
like limiting commitments that are
physically limited by the calendar the
ideal week I really like that all right
final thing to talk about in terms of
navigating our 20s is this idea of
confidence slash finding our true self
um so what advice would you give to
someone who's in their 20s who's maybe
struggling with their Identity or feels
like they don't really know their quote
true self whatever that means the advice
I would give is that the idea of the
true self
is a huge myth and it is going to change
a million times it's going to change at
every turn everything that happens to
you is going to change your your concept
of self
um but what is the main core of that if
your true self doesn't exist what does
exist is your identity and your values
and I think that the important thing to
do in your 20s is to really get a get
kind of a grasp on what those are the
other advice I would say is that it is
so normal to not really know who you are
um in this decade so the way that I I
like to explain it is that
your identity up until the time when
you're like in your late teens has
literally just been
um a mashup of everything in your
surroundings it's been what your parents
have told you to believe it's been what
people have said to you on the
playground it's been what your teachers
have said it's been the media that
you've been consuming the biggest ones
are obviously parental and family
influences and then suddenly you fly the
nest and you have to understand and
decide what parts of that identity do I
actually not believe in and not agree
with I'm going to Chuck those aside what
parts of them of that identity do I
really believe in and I want to really
cultivate that and engage with that and
then one of the new things that are
going to come in that perhaps my parents
don't accept and I think a lot about
this in terms of sexual identity and
people discovering that after leaving
conservative homes or
um your political affiliation or just
your passions and and what really drives
you all those things need to come
together that is going to take time
you're basically learning who you are in
this new context and that idea of the
true self is is such an ambiguous
fleeting feeling I feel like very rarely
do we ever feel like our true selves
because I don't actually think that
there is one version of that that exists
nice I agree uh you mentioned one thing
that might not change so much is your
values yeah what do you mean by that
so your values are essentially
um I would call them like the core
pillars of your identity and your and
yourself so we all know what what values
are the things that we prioritize and
the things that are important to us and
I think that we don't think about them
enough in any any stage of life so
there's this activity that I think is
really valuable for people to do in
their 20s and it's called oh it has a
few names but basically it's like a
value dictionary or
um kind of like a value tapestry where
you really sit down it literally only
takes 20 minutes and just have a real
deep think about what your values are
and what I want you to do is go to
Google or go online and Google like the
top values in the world what are the 200
most common values and print them out
have them on your computer choose 20
that really resonate with you and from
that 20 find get rid of 10 what are the
top 10 and from that 10 pick out your
top five and those five values can be
things like Independence they can be
things like family or honesty creativity
inter intelligence curiosity anything
that you want really but when we take
this approach to really
look at these values and think of them
in the context of how we want to be but
also how we are it's a it's it makes
things a lot clearer about what we want
from our future and how we want to act
and who we want to be so I really
recommend that to a lot of people who
are in this decade as I am I did this
exercise recently and it was really
powerful and seeing and being like am I
actually living my life the way that my
values would tell me too and if that's
not the case
is it the fact that I'm lying to myself
about what my values actually are or am
I just not aligning and living with them
nice
yeah I've tried similar similar
exercises
um quite often
I always like it it's like because when
when you get these lists of like 200
values like basically all of them seem
reasonable okay because No One's Gonna
have the value of like murder or like
destruction like that tends not to be
honestly it tends to be honesty
Integrity like Friendship Community
togetherness autonomy Independence
freedom and all these like things
compassion kind of like where you're
like damn I've got to pick just 10. but
I find that really narrowing it down is
is really just about fully being honest
with yourself and it's less about you
know I aspire to Value compassion kind
of thing and more about
um to be honest I probably Value
Independence more than a value
compassion and just like those difficult
choices where you're honest with
yourself for me the ones that always
come to the top of the list are the
freedom autonomy Independence related
ones and
and so that you know doing those
exercises I discovered these during
lockdown initially that really helped me
decide what to do with my career because
I was like well however I cut it
whichever find your values exercise I've
done on the Internet it's always landed
on Independence autonomy Freedom being
like the absolute number one
so cool medicine is probably not not
necessarily the career for me because
it's a little bit misaligned with that's
with that specific value
um and things like togetherness or
Community is often fairly high up on the
list and I feel like yeah you know when
I was at University I'd love having
people around I love having an open door
policy people are welcome whenever it's
like I like creating that sense of
community and togetherness whereas for
other friends of mine their value might
be you know not related to that or where
they value their own private space which
I don't really so things like that you
kind of just realize by doing these
exercises that what is actually
important and forcing yourself to narrow
it down just three or five then becomes
a lens through which you know is one way
to make decisions yeah
I love that
any other strategies or tools that you
recommend for people to get a sense of
who they who they truly are or what they
what they really value the one that I
think deserves a mention here
um when it comes when it comes to living
authentically and being your most
authentic self is to get comfortable
with disappointing people and get
comfortable with the idea that not
everyone is going to like you
that links a lot to what we were talking
about in terms of Korea but I I honestly
think that that advice that habit that
that tip is applies to every single area
that we've talked about today
you kind of have to realize that at the
end of the day this is really your life
like you don't owe anything to anyone
if you're like a parent you obviously
own being like you know there are some
exceptions but in terms of the way that
you live your life and who you choose to
be
um not everyone is going to accept that
and you have to be okay with that
because you have to realize that
your time is not their time and
regardless of whether Everyone likes you
or not your life like I said life is
going to go on do you want to be happy
or do you want to be miserable because
those people are not going to be happy
they've already made their choice
um you can make a different one and
decide to be an authentic individual and
also authenticity is so attractive and
it just it just makes people so
attracted to you and you will find more
like-minded beautiful people who will
Build You Up rather than try and tear
you down
nice I love it Tim I think that's a
great place to to round this off uh any
final pieces of wisdom for anyone who's
navigating this quarter life struggle in
their 20s
um I think my final piece of wisdom is
just head down you'll get through it
um it's super common and I think part of
the experience can be isolating but the
fact that you and I are talking about it
today shows how common it actually is so
you're not alone in in that experience
brilliant thank you so much no worries
all right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye